um okay this is winterfell this is but
also by ted
uh nate smith yeah ted nashville smith
um and this is where the story begins
for
you know for your readers um
but now you know at the point that we
are in the story now it's been sort of
destroyed and that is killed and
there's something sort of really sad
about looking at a picture of it now
and it made me want to maybe wonder um
i know you're willing to
tear down beautiful castles and kill
popular characters if when you feel like
you need to
but do you ever end up missing them once
they're gone yeah i do miss them
some of them
the bad ones as well as the good ones
well sometimes yeah good villain is hard
to replace
but as i said in the book all men must
die
there is something that appeals to me
about
runes and
i don't know beauty that's that has been
uh destroyed or
something like that i was reflecting uh
you know i own a movie theater in santa
fe new mexico where i live
much smaller one than this theater and i
walked in here and said it's a pretty
cool theater too i like old theaters
30s movie palaces and so forth we had a
we had a guy
who uh new york photographer actually
her name is matt lambros
and he has a website called after the
final curtain he came to the cocktail
and did a slideshow for us an art
exhibition of his photographs
he specializes in traveling around the
country photographing
defunct theaters some of them movie
palaces and others
vaudeville theaters and things like that
that have been closed
be it for five years or 50 years and
they're still there they're they're
rotting they're decaying uh
some of them are far gone some of them
are almost look like they were just
closed yesterday but there's
a strange beauty to all of those so
there is something
beautiful about uh runes i mean when i
when i tour you when i go to europe you
know we don't have any castles here in
america but when i go to europe i
i like to visit castles but i i my
preference is always the
the rune castles the way i can clamor
over the rooms and
try to imagine the way it was or or at
least the castles that were fortresses
rather than the ones that maybe called
the castle but they're really like a
uh a palace from from the jacobi and age
and
and they're full of antique furniture
and uh
now that they're uh they're a four-star
hotel you know those are
those have their appeals but give me a
good rune any day